si vous avez un courrier vous c'est sûr
noté alors on se réveille à déployer à
les écrire c'est moi qui ai pris du
temps pour les créer c'est pour vous
j'ai pris mon temps parce que j'essayais
de quebecor de faire des rimes un
rebelle mais c'est un courrier c'est un
courrier où il roule donc en courrier de
coeur oui mais tant il fut marié je vous
ai déjà dit moi que jamais les hommes
mariés mais je veux quand même aimé ah
oui loin on peut aimer d'amour nick
platonique et d'emploi de ninon bien
respectueux la toya plate
yannick bien sûr alors les voici du
plateau vous allez avoir des problèmes
ce soir vous n'êtes jamais vous aimez
écouter je vous écoute alesi toujours
plus mon bain jama j'ai toujours aimé
ton côté taquin coquin mais jamais
autant je disais hier encore devant
témoins que tu es toujours le même dès
le matin jovial parfois sanguin ouvert
aux autres et pas radin un homme sain un
homme de soins j'espère que même demain
si la vie est plus chagrins tu resteras
toujours aussi divin pour cette équipe
chez un écran
[Musique]
non
il faut faire un petit môme qui dédicace
à non mais pas du tout alors l'effet
bénévolement
j'ai beaucoup d'activités bénévoles